[Music]
[Applause]
rob demofsky of espn nfl nation covers
the packers he's been covering the
packers since
1997.
if i didn't watch the game how would you
describe it rob
uh aaron rodgers was playoff aaron
rodgers and the packers special teams
was the packers special teams for the
last 15 years
both bad
um you said rogers was playoff rogers
yeah is that a good thing or a bad thing
well dan since the super bowl uh in 2010
and i remember talking to you in the
airport in dallas
flying home from that super bowl and i
remember us talking about the
possibility of a dynasty well they
haven't even been back to a super bowl
let alone 1-1 his record in 16
playoff games since the super bowl is
seven and nine i mean that's the season
right or at least that's what a season
used to be right 16 games uh i think
that's enough evidence to tell you that
he's a subpar some
uh 500 postseason quarterback and if you
think about it he's really had like
two great playoff games
since then and that's both the dallas
games in 14
and 16. uh look he is a fantastic
quarterback and if you ask me if i'd
rather have him
or take my chances with an unknown i
would definitely take him there's no
doubt about that you want to be in
position to be in the playoffs but it's
a little surprising to me
that his playoff record and performance
isn't better than it's been
and i was wondering about this rob that
we keep waiting to hear from aaron like
does aaron want to play does he want to
come back and i'm thinking
aren't the packers the ones in control
here
well you know that's a great point i i
would say
uh
48 hours ago i would have said this is
pretty much all aaron rodgers decision
uh
the last 48 hours since that game ended
i think the packers do have to look at
it and say is it going to happen here
you know is it going to happen with him
matt leflore told us after the game we'd
be crazy not to want him back but and
matt lafleur obviously is it part of the
decision but he's not the only decision
maker i do think that it's still more
roger's call than the package but i
think there's probably some
conversations being had
across town at 1265 lombardi avenue
discussing that exact thing yeah because
i i kept thinking well what's it going
to cost you can you afford devante adams
is there a part of you that do you want
to go through this again in the off
season or when he shows up at camp or
everything else that kind of goes along
with him and
do you
you know if you trade him let's say to
denver and you get whatever picks for
him
uh decide what you want to do with
devonte adams can you afford him um i'm
just trying to figure out what makes the
most sense for the packers as much as
you say we can't let aaron rodgers walk
this is a organization that's made tough
decisions before
and it's still
are you in a rebuild are you just going
to reload
yeah i don't know that it's a it's a
rebuild except from for one position the
quarterback position if rogers doesn't
come back and you you heard him say
right i don't want to be a part of a
rebuild the soundbite that you didn't
hear
the question i asked him was uh do you
think if you do come back that you have
enough pieces
to make a legitimate run given the fact
that like you said devonte adams is a
free agent given the fact that they've
got all these salary cap uh constraints
and roger said
i don't know that's a fair question
definitely something i've considered and
i know you're asking about from the
packers standpoint but from roger's
standpoint even he looks at it like
maybe we may not have
enough even if i do come back so the
question is how big of a rebuild is it
and i think the answer is in part how
good the next quarterback is or is not
is jordan love the future quarterback
he will get a chance to be but at this
point after two seasons
no one can sit here and say for sure
that he's the guy now at this point uh
with rogers i don't know that we could
say that either it was in that third
season you remember in 07 when farv got
hurt in that game down in dallas and
rogers played lights out almost they
didn't win the game but they were down
big time and that was the first time i
think everybody walked out of there
going okay i can see why they drafted uh
rogers i can see that there's a chance
that he might be the next guy we've seen
jordan love
you know play obviously a full game in
kansas city play uh half a game in
detroit in that meaningless regular
season finale and i don't think there's
anybody that's willing to say yeah i can
see it
rob demosky covers the packers nfl
nation packers reporter and he's been
covering this team since 1997. you know
when you put together farv and rogers i
mean we're talking three decades and you
got two super bowls yeah
um is that just a coincidence
you know
let me say this dan last year uh when
the packers were playing saints
uh we had a uh
one of our editors at espn.com wanted to
do a story on why rogers and brees
haven't won more super bowls and you
know what my answer was it's really
freaking hard to win super bowls you
know like
again yeah should they have gone to more
like do we feel differently about
the farv tenure because at least he got
to a second one they didn't win it right
i mean they won in 96 and lost as a two
touchdown underdog to the all right
sorry two touchdown favorite excuse me
to the broncos should we feel better
about that than we do about rogers only
getting to one
you know you can make that argument or
you could just make that argument that
that they didn't get enough out of 30
whatever it is years of incredible
quarterback play and what are the
chances that they're able to sustain
that for another generation of
quarterback play
i want you on record so we can bring it
back
the starting quarterback for the packers
week one is
so let me just say this they asked me
this on i think one of the espn radio
stations like last may and i said i
thought there was less than a five
percent oh i remember
i'll tell you what i am now like people
who i want to come at me i missed your
five percent what do you have to say now
mr five percent
uh i i i just i hate to do this but i
just don't know
i thought he was going to be back this
season i don't think he's going to be
back next season
and i'll make it clear like
like i'm not rooting for one way or
another like it's it's a compelling
story either way and and you know dan
you you can't spell media without me we
want a good story so you know whatever
the best story is going to be that's
that's what i would like to see happen i
have no
if he comes back great if he doesn't
come back that's fine too we'll tell the
story either way more likely to retire
aaron rodgers or tom brady
tom brady
okay
do you think rogers is playing somewhere
next year
i mean
you know look i i know i
said what i said about his playoff
performance but man i mean the year he
can still play right i mean like he's
still gonna give somebody whether it's
these guys
you know or denver pittsburgh whoever it
may be uh he's gonna give somebody the
chance to make a run whether he does it
or not you know that remains to be seen
he can still play and they would trade
him to an afc team they wouldn't allow
him to come back and haunt him in the
nfc
yeah remember in the summer of 08 when
uh they traded they traded five to the
jets ted thompson the general manager at
the time went to bret and said i've got
a deal with tampa and i've got to deal
with the jets they're basically the same
which one do you want and farm says i
want to go to tampa so they sent them to
the jets
just send him to the lions then he can't
haunt you
yeah there's that too hey rob thank you
i know you got a busy day we appreciate
your time as always
yeah always great to see you there mr
five percenter i like that rob demofsky
espn nfl nation packers reporter